Five,
four,
three,
two,
one.
Gary Vee.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Dude,
I have gotten so many fucking tweets
about you ever since I say we're going
to do this podcast or I don't know if I
announced it online or tweeted or
something.
Man,
that you are.
You're doing something out there.
Dude.
You got a lot of people behind you.
Lot are people excited about you.
Well,
listen,
I'm super thrilled to be here.
I,
I really appreciate it.
I appreciate you being here.
I'm thrilled to talk to you.
Thanks.
You're a motivational motherfucker,
man.
You got a lot of people up and Adam,
I'm super grateful.
You know.
Do you know it's funny.
I,
uh,
I spent the three years for the last
year.
I've been okay with it,
but the three years prior to that,
I specifically didn't want to be a
motivational speaker.
How come I was selfish in deciding like
that?
I just didn't want to be that,
that I was more proud in my own mind of
being an entrepreneur or business
builder who happened to have
entrepreneurial tendencies.
And I feel like the motivational speaker
thing,
you know,
by percentages can get a little ugly,
gets a little kind of hollow,
a little spammy.
And for my own mind,
the way I had it,
my brand was I suppressed and stop
putting out the content like that.
I would tell my boys and my internal
employees,
but for the last year I embraced it a
little more.
And so,
you know,
it's got a place,
I mean,
you can't,
I know you feel this because as soon as
you announced it too,
I've gotten so many emails and tweets
and the ems of the same thing,
if you're lucky enough that some way,
the way you communicate brings value to
others.
You need to be smart about that.
And so I'm trying to figure it out.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah.
I mean I definitely think you need to be
smart about it.
You definitely don't.
You don't want to get greedy with it or
stupid with it or there's a fine line.
But the population and you know,
and doing the right thing for sure.
And for me,
when I go onstage,
that is my zone.
Like I,
that's like,
that's my arena,
that's my court.
I just don't think anybody does it
better.
Like when you give a motivational
speech,
usually business talks,
but um,
so like Rah,
Rah,
that takes,
you know,
I feel like I'm a defensive coordinator
that's giving you the place,
but I'm going to give it to you,
like we can do this,
let's rip their next,
you know,
like out of their body.
And so when I'm up there that and the
youtube videos and things of that
nature,
that's the majority of what people see
of me.
And that's the only one version of it.
And uh,
yeah,
I,
I'm very conscious of the motivational
thing.
I think a lot of people use motivation
for their own selfishness.
And I'm trying.
I know it all plays out in 30 or 40
years,
but along the way for my own appetite,
I want to balance it the right way.
Well,
there's a lot of people that are doing
it that haven't,
they don't really,
they don't really do anything else.
Like I know a guy who does motivational
speaking,
used to be a shitty comedian and now
he's just doing these weird motivational
speeches and they're like,
there's sort of hobbled and cobbled
together from other people's Shit.
And it's like it's fake.
You know what?
Listen,
I don't judge anybody very honest.
I don't give a fuck really.
I really don't really.
I don't.
But about what other people are doing.
Entertainment,
escapism.
Just,
you know,
people can say reality stars of this.
People say watching football,
like my beloved jets for three hours of
stupid.
Like people can judge escapism in any
way they want.
Here's my big thing.
I'm a businessman,
so I talk about business content.
It's not just finding your inner peace,
right?
Scares the shit out of me is everybody
who fucking says that they're a business
coach and they've never made a fucking
dollar outside of selling other people
how to make a dollar.
The scheme is basically sell other
people on how to make a dollar.
So I just don't want to go down that
path and I think I can look the part
very quickly and that's why suppressed
it for a little while,
but then in the last three or four years
I've built a very large agency,
a media agency,
and so I think I felt good that I went
and executed again,
just like I did when I built the wine
business.
So I filled that bucket of building
another big business,
which makes me feel more comfortable to
go out and do the content and being out
there.
Well there's definitely value in giving
people motivation is definitely value
that other people get from it.
It's a real positive thing and there's
ripples that come off of that.
And I feel like I gained a lot from a
lot of people that are motivational.
I get a lot out of it.
I love it when they're real.
When the real.
Yeah.
It's just,
it's hard to find,
you know,
you've got to separate find out who's a
boat,
you know,
who's a real health expert and who's a
bullshit artist that is sort of compiled
and remembered a bunch of things that
other health experts have actually
studied and done headline research on
versus practitioners should imagine what
you guys are dealing with.
Being at the top of the sphere of this
important medium,
you must get bombarded and it takes
work.
Like I've been able to navigate who I
want to fuck with and have drinks with
and who I stay away from.
It takes a lot of time.
Yeah,
does because it can look the part and
you got to like dig and then you gotta
like take and you know,
you know this,
there's people that you actually respect
who haven't done the work and are lazy
about putting somebody else on and our,
yeah,
that's a good guy,
but they're not.
And they're like,
fuck.
I'm like,
you know,
the whole thing is really interesting.
And then there's hosers mess.
There's a lot of hoses out there.
There's just no,
there's no getting away from that though
and kind of all walks of life and I
think you're right though,
did not concentrate on the negative ones
because it's really just a waste of
resources.
It's a waste of energy.
But this is an amazing time though to
get a message out there and to motivate
people and to show people that,
you know,
there's,
there's something positive not just in
being inspired buttons.
Inspiring others.
Yeah.
I mean,
listen,
you know,
the communication infrastructure of
society is incredibly interesting right
now,
but you and I are doing,
do you know,
I mean like if you map what you're doing
right now,
like it's insane.
You,
you basically had to give up all the
economics to the biggest radio station
in the world.
Like,
like everybody can reach so many people
and of course everybody's gonna head's
going to go to what's going on in
politics and what's going on.
And it's true,
the reason that dictator when they're
creating a coup d'etat wants to take
control of the media is because people
go with what the media is telling them.
And so yeah,
I mean I think it's imperatively
important to try to navigate and
distinguish yourselves.
To me,
I'm saying this quite a bit lately,
which is if you're feeling good right
now,
it's like,
for example,
I am,
I feel enormously optimistic.
You have a massive sense of
responsibility to communicate that
because the wave of negativity is
extreme.
Yeah,
I agree.
And I think it's super beneficial.
And um,
you know,
what you were saying about the media
being powerful.
I mean the most powerful thing about it
is everyone has access to it now.
It was nothing keeping anyone from
starting an instagram page and just
putting up little videos everyday of how
they feel and how they think.
And it might only affect one person.
It might affect a thousand people,
it might get to a million people.
And it builds.
And what happens,
Joe,
is I think people look at this in a
cynical way.
They're like,
social media is bad.
That person has no talent.
Why are they successful?
This political thing is going on.
That's bad,
this is bad.
And what they don't realize is these
social networks haven't changed us.
They've exposed us.
You know what people like twitter didn't
change your opinions.
Twitter allowed you to express them.
Back in the day when something was on tv
or the radio.
We were yelling when I used to listen to
sports radio,
Mike and the mad dog in the nineties in
Jersey,
I was yelling back at mad dog,
like,
you idiot,
no,
the jets should do this.
But now that voice is in play,
right?
Right.
One famous person away from retweeting
it to getting the foundation.
That's the,
you know,
that's the match.
That can start your infrastructure.
Not only is it in play,
but if you have opinions on sports,
you could start your own podcast and it
just builds.
And it could be massive in bigger than
anything on the radio because it's such
a superior medium.
People forget that blogging was a
precursor to this.
I mean,
where do you think Bill Simmons came
from?
People were confused,
like people forget real quick.
I mean,
that was my story.
I owned a wine store in Jersey.
Youtube came out.
It was five months old and I'm like,
this thing is going to be big and it's
sad to sit in front of a table,
drink four bottles of wine for 20
minutes,
and it was good enough that a lot of
people want to watch what you started
out.
That's what you started doing.
My Mike.
So My,
if you want to take it all the way back.
I was born in Belarus in the former
Soviet Union,
so I have a very immigrant story.
Came to the states in [inaudible] 78.
Lived in a studio apartment half the
size of this studio with eight family
members.
Real immigrants.
Shit.
My Dad got a as a stock boy in a liquor
store for two bucks an hour in New
Jersey.
Wow.
Became the manager of that store
eventually.
You know,
that immigrant thing just work every
hour.
Right?
Dad Did.
I didn't even know my dad until I was 14
even though he slept in my home every
night.
And uh,
and we moved to Jersey.
I was straight entrepreneurial DNA,
like lemonade stands,
like shoveling snow.
I used to rip people's flowers out of
their yard and ring the doorbell and
sell it back to them.
It was real raw entrepreneurship and
then I'm 41 baseball cards were like the
thing in 87,
88,
89 90.
That was culture and I became a baseball
card dealer and I was making two,
$300 a weekend selling baseball cards in
the malls of New Jersey that my dad
owned a small liquor store.
Eventually in Springfield,
New Jersey dragged my ass in.
I hated it,
but around 16 I realized people
collected wine that was connected to
what I liked,
which was collecting baseball cards and
football cards and I at 16 years old,
spent every minute of my life trying to
become the foremost expert in wine.
I would go into like science class
junior year and not give a fuck about
Saturn and we'll just sit there and read
the wine spectator and decided I was
going to be the greatest wine retailer
of all time.
Heard the Internet in [inaudible] 94 in
a dorm room playing madden [inaudible]
94.
My friend came and he's like,
you got to see this,
went to a room,
heard cooch,
that whole thing and 15 minutes in was
on a Bolton board and a PSA,
seeing that people are selling wine and
decided that I would launch a wine
website and in 1996 I launched one of
the first ecommerce wine businesses in
America.
Wow.
And so then in 98 I came home full time
and from 90 to 2003 in that five year
window I built my dad's business from a
three to a $60,000,000
business on the back of email marketing,
google ad words and just having a
website and that became my first foray
into using technology to grow very
quickly.
Sell wine through that website.
Eat.
So buy and sell.
I don't know Jack Shit about one I go
to.
I just asked the guy,
what's good dude?
Do you like it?
Love it.
That's all you need to know.
The number one reason I broke out in
wine.
Everyone who's listening right now,
real quick,
take a step back.
Do you know anybody that's into wine?
Everybody probably knows one or two
people,
they know what I know.
Every one of those people are street
douchebag.
Anybody that's really into wine thinks
like it's some magical information that
they impose on others and they become a
straight dick.
Since I knew so much about wine,
I was like,
you know what,
I'm going to take this away from all
those assholes.
So I started the youtube show and I
started comparing the wines to like
Hillbilly Jim's like,
you know,
like boot and like,
like racquetballs and like the gum out
of a tops pack,
all the stuff that actually tastes like
and democratized wine.
And it was a good thing because wine
should not be on a pedestal if you like
it.
Good.
Nobody.
There's no cheeseburger expert running
around going,
Joe,
you're using the wrong cheese.
It's from the wrong.
Right.
It's so douchey that nobody wants to get
into it.
So I was like,
fuck that.
I'm going to help wine.
And it did.
It got a lot of young people
into it.
Yeah.
There's a weird pretentiousness to wine
that doesn't sort of.
It doesn't really exist with a lot of
other liquors,
like it doesn't exist with Tequila.
Well,
you're seeing it right?
Like craft beer,
you're seeing it with Breadski,
a craft beers more down home and it's
Kinda cool.
But you know what Brooklyn heads that
are trying to be Douchey as to.
Well Brooklyn's a rough spot.
It's a weird spot.
So confused and thinks it's like North
Carolina thinks it's Asheville,
North Carolina,
like planted in the middle of New York
City.
It's for what a weird place Brooklyn is
right now.
And it wasn't like that when I was
living in New York at all.
Now when I lived in New York,
Brooklyn was kind of like rough.
It was like Guido's and you know,
and uh,
urban.
It was a,
it was a different spot and now it's
just all these weird hipsters,
skinny jeans and fucking vests on and
half.
It's probably you listening,
love your genes.
See what I'm saying?
Monday while they're doing it,
they can even run on those things that
you have to get away with something
chasing you guys are getting away from
it and not getting away.
They just accept their fate and not
stealing their role,
their pants up,
keep it tight.
You know,
they're,
they're paying six x the price of
whatever in North Carolina for the same
item.
Why?
Yeah.
I don't get that.
I don't,
don't even get that living together
thing.
Everyone's smushed into that one spot.
It just seems like that's a retro that I
love.
I live in Manhattan.
I liked it.
I can't live anywhere else.
I definitely could.
I call it way,
but I really prefer not.
Why do you like to be smashed?
Him like that.
I need speed.
I need the action to get to other places
like La,
like here we are.
Right.
And like there's nothing going on here
at 11:00
PM tonight.
Trailer is you just got to go to the
city.
That's fine.
But right out here in Woodland Hills?
No,
but like yes,
fish.
Yes.
Fish but not Manhattan Ish.
No,
and not that that's bad by the way.
It's probably mainly good for 99
percent.
I just know what I'm about.
Like I like it.
I like,
I like the action.
You like there being a restaurant open
at 1:00
AM,
you can get a nice meal at and it's not
even that cool.
I'm not cool enough for that.
Here's what I like.
What do you like noise.
So for example,
what I fucking hate,
right?
So I love it.
So let me give you a good example.
I have to sleep with a sound machine
because I need the chaos when I walk in
my office floor and everybody's got
headphones on and there's no sound.
I freaked my shit.
And like poke somebody in say like blast
your spotify or it like I need sound.
Really man.
I'm the total opposite.
I want to be on a mountain.
I want to hear birds Chirp and nothing
makes me happier than hearing like
sirens and people yelling.
It really puts me to sleep.
Like Lizzie,
Lizzie,
my sister right now.
I know she's listening.
She knows there used to be a train
outside our house in Edison,
New Jersey.
I couldn't sleep.
The train would come by and it'd be like
one of those hips out sound.
That's so weird.
That's why I love social.
That makes sense.
You know what I mean?
Post that it did a reply like I am an
action junkie and luckily I haven't
deployed that against drugs or,
or a little gambling early on,
but I've gotten away from Medicare when
enough to get me excited and I can lose
and get pissed.
So like finally won that game where
you're gambling like Vegas,
gambling our sports vegas.
Yeah.
And like dumb shit,
like roulette.
Like I would just decide like no,
like $500 on the number five because
like fuck,
if I hit this know just like dumb shit.
Like I'm gonna when I go so much for the
UFC gamble at all.
I've never gambled in Vegas.
I've gambled on fights and that's it.
I should really bet baseball.
I've been a hardcore,
like 25 year fantasy baseball player and
so you know,
a lot.
The only time I've ever really made
money gambling was when I new up and
coming pitchers were coming up and
that's how they really run it and that's
where I've made my biggest arbitrage.
It's hard to make money on fighting too.
They used to be able to,
when I used to gamble,
when I first started working for the
UFC,
I'd still bet on fights and then I
thought about it for a while and it's
like,
I'm probably not supposed to do this.
He's like,
it doesn't make any sense.
I couldn't.
I can't affect anything and no one ever
told me I can't do it.
It's not like I'm a manager.
And that your commentary with slate?
Yeah.
That.
Anyway,
they said,
they said that it has been me.
They said I was biased for people I bet
against,
which is hilarious.
I've had that happen,
but I stopped doing that like more than
10 years ago.
It was probably like 2002 or three,
like right after I first started doing
commentary.
I quit doing that,
but used to be able to make a lot of
money because there were some killers
and there were and people were
undereducated and that's,
well there were some killers that would
come in from other countries and I would
go,
you know,
like they didn't know about this guy and
I'd be like,
oh,
this like Atlanta.
I'm a golf guy,
was coming in from,
I forget where he's from,
but I was like,
Jesus Christ,
what is the,
what's the line?
Fucking bet the house,
you know,
there was some guys from parts unknown.
There's a few guys from parts did that
so.
Well.
I was fascinated when they were like
from parts unknown shit.
Where's he from?
Well that's no good for global
enterprise at the UFC because you want
to engage those people in the other
countries.
Like,
like there's this guy,
Habib normal.
Go ahead off.
Who's the number one contender in the
lightweight division?
He says fucking murderer.
He's such a bad ass.
And he's undefeated and like the big
thing about this guy's a,
he's from Russia.
He's from Dagestan.
Yup.
And there's a,
it's a really weird place because it's
not a large place,
but there's a bunch of killers that come
out as one spot and this guy is like the
main killer.
And so they're,
they're planning on doing a big UFC in
Russia.
This guy's fighting in Russia.
It's going to be fucking bonkers,
you know?
So like,
that's a big deal at conor mcgregor in
Ireland and you know,
there's this,
it's a big deal to fight in your
country.
One hundred percent digital thing has
always worked,
you know,
World Cup Olympics.
These are historic things like we're
look,
nationalism is on the rise.
Yeah,
no,
it definitely is.
And,
and even,
you know,
statewide,
like a cowboy serone fought this past
weekend in Denver,
you know,
and he's just from Denver.
And so when he goes to Denver,
they go fucking crazy hometown stuff.
There's,
there's always that,
you know,
it's just,
it's,
it's a fascinating thing.
And that your signature on your fucking
phone case.
That's a little weird there buddy.
I'm a weird dude.
This is,
you know,
you got like a watermark signature
that's a signature by the way that
anybody could rip off.
You'll be super careful.
Your checkbook.
Luckily I don't have any checks.
Sometimes I don't even know what a check
is.
I got a buddy of mine,
his name is Guido Orlando.
He's a good guy and he,
uh,
his signature is this,
it's like,
that's it.
Which was great until he got divorced
and then his ex wife just fucking went
off with the to trench.
Just drain the poor guy.
Or do I still fucking stuck to his guns
though?
After she drained them,
kept that fucking seconds.
He's like,
you can take the money,
but you hadn't taken this signature
taken.
My big old bitch gets.
Nobody could tell you how you write your
name,
you know,
you could write your name a any way you
want.
So he just decided that's how I write
it.
That's it right now.
That's a good question.
He's a pool cue maker.
He makes custom made pool cues.
Yeah.
And last time I heard he was somewhere
in the midwest where pool is still got a
pool,
is always connected to gambling and
it's,
it does better in places where there's
not as much to do.
Right.
Not as many options for gambling.
Although Manhattan is like a good spot
for pool.
It is,
oddly enough.
It's like a date thing,
like you know what I mean?
Pool pool pool.
Like real pool gamblers,
high level players.
Yeah.
I could play,
I could play decent.
What about darts?
No,
a dartboard over there.
Somebody gave it to me.
I never even opened it up over there.
Are you good at darts?
Yeah.
Better than I am.
People love darts.
Just have good hand eye coordination.
It's a fun.
It's fun to play.
Yeah,
but it seems like you're looking at the
same thing over and over again.
That's my problem with bowling and
darts.
You're looking at the same goddamn
thing.
To me.
Pattern recognition.
It's kind of how I think about like,
yeah,
content and business and those things.
I like pattern recognition.
Why do you like pattern recognition?
He comes to me but you like chaos.
I do.
But I.
But I,
you know,
I definitely am a big,
big fan of,
of pattern recognition.
Like to me,
everything just happens over and over
and over again.
You just have to understand the
historics.
So for example,
my great thesis right now where I think
all the money's going to be made,
this is the television and that is the
radio.
So you're pointing to your phone.
It was the television,
the TV,
the radio,
and it's 19,
48 to 1957,
meaning we are going from a primary as a
society in the US.
The primary device in our lives is
switching from the television to the
phone.
The same thing that happened in the late
forties,
early fifties from the radio to
television.
If you go back and understand the
brands,
the media companies,
the personalities,
what happened in that decade,
then you can start making bets on
understanding,
Oh wait a minute.
If the phones,
the television than facebook and twitter
and instagram are ABC,
NBC and CBS.
Shouldn't I become bob hope and seal
ball?
Because if you go back and read a lot of
the radio stars didn't go to television
because they disrespected the medium.
Huh?
So I would tell you,
I asked you this before we went on.
I was fascinating because I know you've
been really a pioneer in this in early
dude.
Like you went to podcasting and I'm sure
now everybody's like,
oh my God and can I be on your show?
But when you first started,
it didn't have the,
you know,
the brand as a platform.
It has now short plenty people were
snickering at it or what does it mean?
That's what it is.
They were doing it reasonably like
people are still doing it.
Howard stern was making fun of podcast
just a couple of years ago,
not even a year ago.
He was mocking people doing it.
Now we get $95,
million downloads a month.
Of course he's mocking it because
everybody mocks the competitive thing
that's rise.
There's that,
there's that.
But it's also.
Yeah,
it is that for sure.
Let's just save ourselves in that way.
Well,
in my opinion,
radios fucked because it's it.
You have to tune in at a certain time.
You have to listen to their commercials.
You have to.
I mean the.
The medium of podcasting is so superior
that it's instantaneous.
You pause it when you want.
You get back into your car,
Bluetooth to your car.
It plays anywhere.
You can go from your car to headphones.
It can play in your car or complain your
headphones.
You could pick it up,
you could put it on your laptop,
you could have it stream in your house,
you do whatever the fuck you want with
it.
You delete them,
you download their.
They're instantaneous.
You can get them whenever you want.
You can go to the archives.
I agree.
I mean,
and it's also a hundred percent
uncensored,
100 percent unproduced.
There's no one in like with this,
it's me and Jamie and that's it.
I mean there's no one else involved in
this.
That's it.
And look at Jamie,
he's just chilling,
but I mean it's really amazing in that
respect.
There's no corporate end.
Like when you get to these kinds of
numbers,
usually you'd be in some giant building
somewhere and there'd be a gang of
people involved.
They'd have meetings and after the show
meetings and a tutorial post and we had.
We never had a fucking meeting ever.
You guys smoke a little weed.
Even talked to each other.
Yeah.
Look,
tell him we're friends,
but a little weed will knock some pool
balls around.
Jamie has a good idea.
We're going,
yeah,
let's do that.
And we fucking wind up doing it,
but it's so informal and it's like
there's nothing going on like corporate.
What's amazing is that allows the talent
to rise to the top.
Well,
it,
it also allows people to be themselves,
which is what allows the talent to rise
to the top or allows the.
Let me say the word talent,
but allows content to find its way in a
pure manner where it's not like if you
have a bunch of people influencing what
you do,
as soon as you start compromising and as
soon as you start compromising,
you just can't.
It's never going to get through the
right way.
Like one of the beautiful things about
standup and one of the beautiful things
about podcasting is that like if you go
to see a guy like bill burr has netflix
specials out right now,
he's in gentleman just came out,
he was on earlier today.
Like you see his thoughts.
There's no one telling him what to say.
There's no one needed to know.
When you watch a stand up on stage,
that's their thoughts.
They figured out a way to hone it to
their personality.
And then boom,
put it out there like that.
And that's the same thing with
podcasting and that's never existed
before.
They've never had the opportunity.
The Internet is the.
We take it for granted.
It's really fundamentally only 20 to 21
years old.
Windows 95 really kind of put normal
people on it is the great shift in our
society and I think we haven't fully
quantified it's impact across the board.
Well if you think about 20 years and
how,
what a short period of time that is in
human history and if we go a hundred
years from now and look back,
they will look at this like this great
explosion of content and creativity and
expansion and integration.
This integration of thoughts and ideas
and the instantaneous ability to
communicate that's just never existed
before and they're going to think it's
slow.
Oh yeah.
I mean this is going to say everybody's
like,
it's so fast.
And the kids,
the kids,
I mean I love these kids are not going
to be capable to live in society because
they're on a phone.
I was told that I would not be a
functioning human being because I played
Zelda and Mike Tyson's punch out too
much while they were right.
They knew it in that way.
I mean,
but I tell my friends all the time,
like,
what world do you think our kids are
going to be living in?
You think it would be outside throwing a
racquet ball against the fucking wall.
Like the world shifted.
Yeah,
there'll be taking selfies of her ass
and that's exactly right.
So they're doing,
they're going to be putting lenses and
let me get a vr world 24 slash seven.
That's what they're really going to be,
is really what they're going to be
doing.
Yeah.
What do you think is next?
Like if you look at the cell phone and
you look at technology and the
integration in our lives,
what do you think is the next step?
Voice voice is going to be really
interesting because it's on us now.
So voice.
So here let's take a step back.
It's all about time arbitrage.
The thing that we're all addicted to his
time.
So Uber,
Uber doesn't sell transportation.
Uber sells time this whole convenience.
That's exactly right.
And it's.
And it's packaged in time.
So voice when Alexa can order your
package for you instead of like
whatever's faster,
like the head of the I pads that we
talked about,
like the yearbook.
Thank you there.
Whatever's faster,
whatever's faster is what we're going to
gravitate towards.
So I think voice activation,
ai,
ar,
those kinds of things are really gonna
start to populate up over the next half
decade.
Those,
um,
those earbuds that you're wearing,
do you work out in those things?
No.
No,
they don't hang in there.
They'll fall out.
I haven't tried it.
I don't.
I'm not quite sure they look.
That's the only thing I would worry
about.
They look pretty bad ass.
I'm upset.
It's the best product that was put out
since the phone itself.
You really believe that.
I really believe that.
Now.
Do they work the way the other way?
Is there a button you can press on them
to answer the phone?
Like how does that work?
I don't know.
The truth is I'm not even sure,
like by the way probably,
but I'm so weirded out like I don't do.
I'm so bad at that.
Like I never get the full value out of
products because I don't even have the
time to read.
That's actually probably good because
that means that a product has to be
really,
really good to impress you because it
becomes so easy to use.
Have very good insight.
Yeah.
No,
seriously.
Yeah.
Because there's some shit like on one of
those fitbit's like good luck with all
that.
I'm not getting in there and pulling up
apple product.
Right.
You know what they're gonna do.
They're gonna make all that ship.
Not work stuff.
They're not.
They're not here to be friendly.
They want your fucking money.
Somebody gave me one of these gps
watches that you have to charge every
other day or some fucking stupid shit.
And the other thing that thing charges,
like I thought it was like that three
days like,
you know,
like instantaneous.
It's been really good.
It lasts for three days.
Mine have been lasting for as long as
three days here.
Yeah,
I ordered it,
but they're not going to deliver it
until March.
I think they're back ordered for quite a
while because too many people like you.
Maybe you can predict it up.
You fucked it up,
dude.
Sorry everyone.
I like it.
So you think voice meaning like voice
control voice and I'm one of the things
that I use all the time as a comic is
the notes feature on the iphone yet has
that little voice thing and it's
amazingly accurate and accurate enough
that I could realize what I'm saying.
Like even if it fucks up a word or
something like that,
I can go back and look at it.
But if you've ever used it.
Yeah,
I do.
It's fucking granted.
But I think,
I think it's the two point.
Oh,
of that,
right?
Where like things are actually happening
because of your voice.
So we could talk right now and this
fucking thing is going to be able to
pick up a good 99 percent of everything
we're saying and I'm not even touching
it.
You see it crushed it.
I just Uhm,
killed it.
Perfect.
Yup.
Got It.
One hundred percent.
So to me where it gets really exciting
is when everything around you is being
at.
So when everything becomes smart,
then it starts getting really
interesting.
So our phones are smart,
right?
But what happens when your belt is
smart?
Oh,
and now all of a sudden you go to order
a big Mac and you try to pay with your
phone,
but your belts talking to your phone and
when you go to pay it declines and it
looks at you and says,
order a salad.
Fat Ass,
Woo.
Your belt is telling you it's tightened,
correct.
Tights pushing against your body.
And what about when your refrigerator
reorders?
Another case of Budweiser because it
understands how often you drink it and
so you're down to two.
It knows that you're going to drink to
tonight because that's your average and
as soon as you get home that night and
open and grabbed the first one,
it's already reordering it for you.
So your refrigerator becomes an enabler.
Everything's going to be.
Then they started doing the
refrigerator,
right?
Your traffic,
your toothpaste is going to have one
drop left.
If he orders it for you,
so we're going to get into that place
where everything is smart and that's
when it starts getting a little bit
interesting and then.
And then virtual reality porn is going
to be interesting.
Well it's already interesting.
Have you ever done the htc vive?
You ever fuck with?
Yeah.
Duncan has the porn and the htc vive and
he tried to get me to look at it briefly
and they looked at it briefly like six
hours.
No,
a few days.
It's not,
you're just getting too much.
You know,
you could just stare at someone's tits.
They're just too big.
The whole thing is too weird.
It's just too.
It's not going to be bizarre.
You know,
it was bizarre 10 years ago.
Dating somebody that you met online like
bizarre gets redefined real quick.
Oh for sure.
And guys are real simple.
You know,
all you need is one of your buddies and
five years saying,
Bro,
no,
seriously.
That's it.
Just that tone.
And that was it.
Right?
And You wonder,
you felt where Jamie was like,
no bro.
Seriously.
Well,
how many people are getting laid now
because of online.
It's got to be giant.
Like with tinder and swiping all these
different things.
We missed it.
That's to say.
Yeah,
I mean it seems like probably a bit less
people are in committed relationships
now because it's just a fuck rampage out
there in the streets.
Yeah.
We never recover just a rampage.
But a buddy of mine,
my friend Greg Fitzsimmons,
one of his good friends got divorced and
uh,
you know,
fucking,
the whole deal.
Torturous marriage hung in there too
long.
The whole deal.
No sex for the last year and a half plus
raw,
got out and now he's just on a pussy.
Catastrophic rampage.
I mean there's Dude's just crushing any
sad.
Right?
He's happy,
he's happy.
He's got a giant smile on his face and
his phone's vibrating.
It's amazing.
Yep.
Yeah,
I mean sleepiness and it does.
You don't even have to be a good looking
guy.
He's all right.
But I mean it's not even that carries
water finds its own level so you could
find your level.
You find what it.
Well,
that's exactly who is willing to fuck
you.
They're out there.
They're out there always someone.
Someone's willing to fuck you 100
percent.
True.
You just gotta find that person might
not be everybody.
No,
but what's real fun is when you actually
break out of your level.
Yes.
Once in a blue moon every now and then
every now and then below your level or
above your level.
Every now and then the moment you
actually talk about the three point line
and it's nothing but net.
You're like,
what?
How did that happen?
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
it's just,
it's fascinating to me because I'm
really concerned about the integration
of human beings and technology.
Not Concerned.
I shouldn't say concern,
but puzzled as to the end point.
The end point is the robots kill us all.
You think so?
Yeah.
Really?
Yep.
Why do you think that?
I think we integrate with them.
I think we can come see me until we
become bothering forced to them.
Yeah,
and we don't stop.
Well,
I think it's those pussies that are
scared to integrate that we're going to
have to kill off.
I think it's folks like you and me,
they're going to get the chips so you
think we'll be able to survive on team
robot.
I really killed those humans.
I think there's gonna be some,
some folks that want to make their own
homemade bows and arrows and shit and
chop the.
Yeah,
with a stone ax like those assholes.
I don't use matches.
I'm fucking robe starts to grow those
people,
they're going to be a problem.
I think people can be scared of it.
Like as we continue.
I mean people are scared of technology
for regeneration of it.
I'm real curious how far it gets before
we get to 80,
90,
a hundred.
Like what are we going to really see at
the tail end?
Right.
I mean you think of somebody who's 90
years old now,
the shit they saw.
Like I mean if you go the whole gamut,
like,
like in their forties and fifties,
they're like a television,
you know,
like.
I mean,
so you know.
Do you remember?
How old are you?
Forty nine.
Perfect.
Your little.
I don't know.
I don't know how this plays out for you.
You might have been a slightly.
I'm 41,
so it's slightly.
It'll be interesting to see what you
say.
The jumped from fucking Atari to
Nintendo.
Oh yeah.
Santa giant insanity or the iphone from
the fucking razor or whatever.
So when you have those moments,
that's when it gets interesting when you
have that quantum product that leaps
everything,
the ipod from whatever the MP3 fucking
horseshit things we had said it's going
to be artificial parts too.
I think that's going to be a big part of
it.
Like people who are blind getting them
artificial eyes that worked better than
realize and then people,
you mean initially it's gonna be not as
good and then it's going to be as good
as you were.
80,
60 slash 50.
Now you're 19.
Well not even plastic surgery.
It's going to be genetic manipulation.
I'm saying that the back to pattern
recognition when when plastic surgery
came out,
you are 50 40,
you know that range now,
18 year old girl,
16 year old girls are attacking it
earlier.
So when first it's going to be for the
blind and then some dudes going to be
like,
wait a minute,
fuck this,
why is my friend who was blind can see
shit better than me,
I'm going to just do that.
And it could go from defense to offense.
Somebody showed me a breakdown of Kylie
Jenner's plastic surgery over the years
and she's only like 20 years old.
That's right.
And this girl has had her face just
chopped apart.
She's had her chin widdled down,
she's had her hips widen,
her breast enhance.
She's a little kid.
I get it.
And she's just there.
There's sculpting her with scalpels.
Yep.
It's very,
very,
very strange because she doesn't look
remotely like she used to look just a
couple of years ago.
That's right.
And I'm thinking heralded for it amongst
their peers.
And so what do you think's going to
happen?
People are going to follow that pattern.
Oh,
for sure.
Yeah.
I mean they're jumping in head first
starts with celebrity than it supposed
to.
The affluent.
Well,
the amount of money that it cost to do
something like that.
It's got to be in the hundreds of
thousands of dollars because she's had
some really extensive stuff done.
I mean,
you just didn't see that when we were
kids.
No,
you didn't see a 20 year old girl that
hadn't been.
Maybe a girl got a boob job.
Maybe,
but not even.
I mean it was so rare for later.
You know,
maybe in our twenties we heard about
such stuff.
Wait a minute.
One didn't to do that,
you know,
I get it,
but now it's bizarre.
Like they're doing stuff to their hips,
like girls are getting their hips wide
and because asses the offense now I
don't.
But it's just so strange to see.
Like when you look at a person and you
know their asses mostly like some weird
extra substance that they're sticking in
their lap it up.
But you know what the guys respond.
Like my good friend moves set a long
time ago.
He said good friend named Moose.
Yeah.
Robin use.
We call them loose.
He said about fake boobs.
He's like,
if they're fake,
why can I put them in my mouth?
Yeah.
If I can touch them,
they're real.
It was in 1999 albums.
Yeah.
I think that it's um,
it's,
it's a fascinating thing because we
don't care,
but we do care when it gets to lips,
you know,
there's something about lips were like,
hey,
slow the fuck up.
Like you can get those preposterous tits
and nobody blinks.
But as soon as you get to lips,
gods go Jesus.
Like there's something about when they
have this crazy.
Yep.
The lip implant thing.
That's a strange one,
man.
That is a,
there's something sad about that one
where it elicits a response that you
don't get out of the boobs.
I get it.
Yeah.
I could.
Dude's nothing.
Not a,
not a Dick Implant and site.
Not a goddamn thing you can do to start
happening soon or thing it's going to be
genetic.
Yeah.
And when it happens,
I used to have a bit about that.
It's going to take about 30 minutes for
the first guy to dive and overdose
because they go out with a pill that
makes your dick bigger.
We're not taking one.
We're taking them all just going to go
give me a stroke.
Give me one less than that.
Let's fucking do this.
Simple that way.
Yeah.
Well we're going to morph because
vaginas are going to have to change to
deal with the size of the Dick because
dudes are going to have carpet roll Cox.
It's just going to be this giant.
No,
we're not going to stop like people
don't understand.
Like once we have that ability to get
bigger dicks than once,
it's going to be like those crazy ladies
who bought crushed beer cans with her
tits.
You ever see them?
They get like a triple Z on instagram.
It's going to get to that point.
It's the spot.
Yeah.
It's soft porn though.
I like how they don't go full twitter.
Well that's why I'm glad it's soft porn.
But twitter,
let's use twitter.
You can fuck me.
You can do whatever you want on twitter.
I kinda liked that.
Don't be confused.
Instagram can go there too.
If what you have to be private is to be
a private page.
I mean nothing and then they get pulled.
Tumbler was really there.
Really?
Oh yeah,
nodding furiously.
It investor and Tumbler and the growth
was enormous.
At one point I'm like,
where's all this growth coming from?
I'm like,
Oh,
poor.
Oh well what tumbler at one point in
time became like really tormented social
justice warriors,
making bizarre blogs that are very
difficult for you to understand.
On that note though,
it was a very creative space.
It was,
you say was like,
it's gone,
it's gone.
What happened?
Everybody left is it?
But it's still active,
but no,
I like my space.
Like a club,
like sometimes the clubs,
the hottest club in your city still in
business six years later,
but like it's bridges and tunnels and
shit like that.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah.
Weird bridges and tunnels that people
don't know.
What that means is they give you a
little doing some recall for powerful
Jersey.
Yeah.
It's um,
it's,
it's interesting the trends,
you know,
like why did my space go away like that
because the operators weren't good
enough.
So I'll tell you what's interesting
about the trends in social and business
digital that people don't understand.
Everybody
was waiting for facebook to go away.
It sucks as a beast.
He's an extremely talented all time CEO
and so he was good enough if my space
was run,
first of all,
it's sold to newscorp and so once it was
owned by the big company you talked
about earlier today?
No,
they wanted to milk it.
You know what they did with the first
second?
They got it.
They pump the shit out of their x men
movie that they owned into the platform
because the economics and the movie were
greater than the investment they
thought.
So they were milking it.
Right?
It's like somebody buying this and just
pumping ungodly amounts of whatever
products they thought.
Your audience read into the point where
they just saturated it.
Isn't it weird how something gets a
stink on it and then that's kind of it.
Like no one wants to come along and try
to revamp my space.
That's.
So.
That's another interesting insight.
One of the things that I'm dying to know
in a 15 year window is will there ever
be a recall?
Will something die?
Will anybody,
because I want to buy it to the B,
two b space.
I want to buy a historic brand,
like I want to buy friendster.
First of all,
I just want.
I just want,
I just want the Ip,
so I think nostalgia plays so the same
way.
We talk about like saved by the bell and
that fucking the sparks and I think that
I can buy tumbler in nine years for $40,
Aka $11,000,000
and just make enough on tee shirts to
the kids when they're 40.
They're now 25 that were 15 year olds
doing all those weird sites because
they're like,
yeah,
tell him that it was the best.
You a good point.
Because Jamie and I were looking the
other day at all the Netflix shows,
like what's most popular?
Fuller House is the most popular show.
Bringing everything back to him for just
coming back,
like at 24 is going to be on Netflix now
it's going to be a Fox Fox,
but it's a different 24,
right?
Yeah.
But I mean like,
you know,
yes they're.
But they're bringing the style.
Joe,
my big theory is nostalgia is one of the
most under priced assets in the world.
So,
so my entire thesis in business,
so I want to buy the New York jets.
Let's take a step back.
Yes.
Really?
And I'm going to.
Oh my God.
And I'm so.
It's a very good.
I'm going to make it happen.
So the way I think I'm going to buy the
jets and the reason I built my company
gonna sell friendster.
No,
but I'm going to go and buy Mug croupier
or animal crackers or cracker jacks or
or rainbow pops.
I'm going to buy a brand and then market
it like it's 20,
20 instead of the Horse Shit TV
commercials and fucking billboards and
print and all the bullshit that these
companies do.
Right?
And then I'm going to buy it for $130
million,
do my thing and then resell it for two
point 3 billion by the jets,
win super bowls and then I can die.
Damn Dude,
that's the ultimate goal.
That's the plan.
Brother.
Own the jets.
Yes.
But you don't.
You think that you're the kind of guy
that you'll own the jets and go,
you know what I'm saying?
It's not enough what I need to win super
bowls.
Right?
So I'm going to be like crazy.
Like I'm going to make all these crazy
owners seem calm.
I'm going to be like,
I'm going to do shit like I'm going to
play.
I'm really a 71
year old wide receiver.
Oh,
don't do that.
Maybe you couldn't do that once.
Genetic engineering kits to the point
where they could just to come out with
my fucking let's.
I'm going to come out with my fucking
bionic eyes and let's look and run a
four,
3:40
with my new fucking feet.
Yeah.
Brian made from like duck fucking ass or
whatever.
You know?
Yeah.
Like when they integrate a.
What was that article about?
Their integrating spider silk into a
human tissue.
They're grading artificial skin for
human beings.
Were they going to integrate spider silk
into human tissue to make it
bulletproof?
That's fucking Rad.
Yeah.
That's a real thing.
I heard the Peter Teal and I want to
make sure I'm saying this,
but I think till they leave.
This is bulletproof skin made from
spider silk proteins and human skin
cells.
By the way,
guys,
this is all coming.
Awesome.
Peter Teal,
but it might be some other.
A mogul and silicon valley is,
is putting young blood in himself.
It is him.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
So is that going to work?
Well,
it's kind of like ask him do it.
It's bullets based.
This is the theory that it's based on.
Forget about getting like a log dick.
Tell me something that won't let me die
and that I will definitely do.
Well,
not only will not let you die,
which is entirely possible.
It's going to extend your life,
but more importantly,
it'll give you more energy while you're
alive now,
which makes it fascinating because
you're going to be able to do the thing.
Yeah,
fuck you.
I'm thinking about doing it tomorrow.
I might fly up.
What about the spider doing that too?
Go ahead ma'am.
Shoot,
bitch.
At the thing is that bullet will destroy
your bones.
That's so they're going to have to do
something with the bone.
They're going to have to give you some
read Adam and tanium bones underneath,
because like the spider silk,
nothing gets so jacked in like four
minutes.
What does he do that 100 percent?
One thousand percent.
One million percent good.
And he also does intermittent fasting,
so he drops a lot of body fat.
Got It.
You know,
you get into a state of Ketosis,
you don't eat for 14 hours.
He pounds like low fat,
low carbohydrate,
high fat,
high contact.
So this,
his body's burning fat.
He's doing tons of steroids.
I'm sure.
Allegedly.
I don't know you.
You seem like a nice guy.
I'm not shitting on you buddy.
I like them.
I'm a big fan.
I like Hugh Jackman.
Yeah,
it was fun,
but I think he's on steroids.
Just sure.
Yeah.
I'm just telling you I'm an expert in
that shit.
I can tell.
I mean it's very difficult to look the
way he looks without doing them.
Very,
very,
very difficult.
Excuse me the other day and I'm like,
man,
he fucking beefs up fast.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well,
he does the right shit though,
you know what I mean?
But that's the thing about like saying
someone does steroids,
it's not enough like you.
It's not like he takes a pill,
a conversation that might train.
So I started working out three years ago
finally taking this serious.
I've had two,
two trainers full time.
They travel with me.
I've really gotten into it.
I've got my life damaged.
How many trainers I've had,
I've had,
I only have one trainer at a time and
they travel with you,
but they travel with me.
So I was really out of shape,
like come never worked out,
didn't have a muscle my fucking body
three years ago.
And I'm like,
I'm gonna die.
This is stupid and I can afford it.
I'm going to hire.
I'm not held accountable to myself,
but I'm very good at being accountable
to others.
That's why I run good businesses.
I don't want to let the team down.
So I figured it out.
I fucking found the binary switch.
So I hired somebody and they travel with
me.
Well that's so days.
That's an awesome idea because it will
force you to work out.
Both of them are.
No,
not with them.
The first guy,
Mike is like,
like it was interesting.
He wasn't saying do steroids,
but it was interesting to hear a
perspective of like,
peep.
I've been fascinated by the steroid
conversation in general.
Like I think certain things become taboo
and then they don't like marijuana.
Right?
Is Steroids that I'm asking you because
I feel like you're closer to that genre
than I am.
Well,
they most certainly work 100 percent.
So let's go.
Let's go over that first.
Let's take it from step by step.
Here's what's important.
It's very important that young people
don't do them and this is why because
you ruined your endocrine system.
It's very important that young people
realize that if you do get an 18 now
even into your twenties,
when you do steroids and you're a young
person and you have a healthy endocrine
system,
what happens is you inject exogenous
steroids or exotic testosterone into
your system.
It shuts down your natural production of
testosterone and then you're fucked
because then when you get off the
steroids,
your body doesn't work right.
Your testicles aren't functioning
correctly and it takes you roughly
depending on the person and depending on
how you treat it,
like what,
what treatments you use to kickstart
your endocrine system.
Again,
half the time you want to steroids to
recover.
So if you did a two month cycle for one
month,
you're going to be miserable and your
Dick's not going to work.
Got It.
So it's very important for young people.
However,
once you get older,
like I'm 49 and it becomes sort of that.
That's why people do it,
put him in.
Well because it's a self esteem enabler,
right?
For a guy.
And if I'm a guy right now and I feel
like I need the muscles for the
summertime,
he's like,
I'm going to go on a cycle for two
months.
I'll have a shitty fucking ma may or
April and that will be ready to roll.
Yes.
No,
you know,
you should get your blood work
monitored.
Like if you're really considering doing
something.
I think the most important thing is to
do very little to do just a small amount
and give yourself a little boost.
You don't want to go fucking hog wild
and take some Androgel 50 and turn into
a fucking gorilla.
You don't want to do that because it's
too much of a shock to your system.
However,
when you're in your forties like you
are,
then testosterone replacement therapy
becomes a very viable alternative
because your body is just simply not
producing testosterone correctly.
However,
can we use gorilla because I just got
excited.
You could.
You could kind of.
You could still take some time,
but here's the thing,
like the Hugh Jackman thing,
because when I get back to that,
that motherfucker works hard.
There is no way you look like that
unless you work hard,
so you have to do like really,
really,
really hard.
You got to do fucking heavy dead lifts,
heavy squats.
You've got to shock your system.
You're got to get your body to think,
Holy Shit.
This crazy asshole wants to carry around
gigantic amounts of weight.
We're fighting against gravity.
We have to incorporate all of our
resources.
Your body does not want to use resources
to get bigger.
It just doesn't.
It resists it because it's not.
It's not healthy and it's not a smart
survival tactic like for your body to
put on all this meat.
Then all that meet needs fuel,
like your body's not totally convinced
you're going to have this fuel because
for thousands and thousands of years,
food was very,
very difficult to come by.
So for your body to be convinced that
you're doing this all the time,
we need this extra mass like you have to
have massive amounts of food and massive
amounts of work that's hugely important.
And then steroids,
those things too,
but more important than steroids is
balancing your diet out,
making sure your nutrient levels are all
consistent.
They're all healthy,
that you have the proper amount of
vitamin B,
Vitamin D,
All these different essential nutrients,
essential fatty acids,
all the proper amino acids,
like a steroid is just a bandaid on an
account a least five days a week,
at least five days a week.
Zero.
Jamie runs a lot.
He's a fucking stud.
But um,
you know,
I do a lot of different shit.
I love Jamie's.
He's a fucking runner.
You how many miles you run a lot of
miles right now.
I told you,
I'm like,
I'm doing weight lifting and I just get
back into basketball,
shooting hoops this weekend.
When you were at your peak of running,
you running some pretty impressive
numbers of miles a week.
Easily.
Yeah,
that's back to basketball.
I just put up a post so I didn't let my
brother Aja score on me and he's 11
years younger than me until he was like
15 score score.
You wouldn't let them know.
I'm a.
So I'm my four year old guy.
He's got,
he's got a Zander,
my little guy,
he's got a weird condition when he picks
up the basketball he starts kind of
weirdly crying cause he knows dad's
going to come out of somewhere and block
the fucking shit out of him.
And so I posted this thing about it
today on instagram and it was funny to
watch everybody.
I mean everybody's in these fucking
eighth place trophies.
I'm going to kill people like all this
fucking infrastructure of fake fucking
self esteem and then these kids go into
the market and they get punched in the
mouth and they don't know what to do.
So you don't let your kids score and you
either know.
That's hilarious.
I will not let I'm,
I'm,
I'm fucking gonna.
Beat the like until he could win,
then he's good.
Like age.
My brother has a better basketball
player than me because I didn't let him.
Like,
what?
What are you going to let people score
for?
That's a very interesting perspective.
Let me give you mine,
please.
I don't.
Um,
I don't think you should ever be very
competitive with people who are not
competitive with you.
So here's a perfect example.
An interesting thing.
When I do Jujitsu,
I'm a black belt in Jujitsu,
Jujitsu with a white belt.
I treat them very kindly.
I,
I might tap them out a little bit,
but I,
there's no way I roll with them the way
I roll with another black belt.
Well,
that's fighting in that there's a
difference.
It's not a statement.
It's a game.
The game respect.
So what like when,
like if I'm rolling with someone and
they're making mistakes,
I'll correct their mistakes if I want it
to.
If I'm wrong with someone who's a white
belt,
I could just cut right through them,
just keep cutting right through them.
But you know what you do with them,
you discourage people from doing it and
it's not really fair because you're not
getting anything out of it either.
All you're getting out of you're
practicing like a grappling dummy and
like occasionally maybe that's a good
thing to do.
I feel like once you get into the blue
belt and purple belt range,
then I'm going to go with you 100
percent because when you're dealing with
someone who's not really competitive
with you,
it doesn't make sense.
You're not getting anything out of it
really.
You know?
I think.
I think it's an interesting perspective.
So what you really lovely like kids kick
the shit out of me.
I have an eight.
Anyone martial arts?
I have an eight year old and she's.
She's allowed to punch me and kick me
full blast.
She doesn't kick the shit out of me.
Yeah.
Of course,
but she's 50 pounds,
but she leg kicks me full blast.
I mean I don't ever hit her back.
She,
she sets up leg kicks,
she throws a left hook to the body and
then she comes around with that right
leg kick.
WHAP whap.
And as long you mean she's allowed to
hit me full blast.
So like she'll,
she'll go,
can I hit you on?
All right,
go ahead and she'll just tee off on me.
So it gets her used to doing it now if I
like.
Every time she went to do that,
I checked it and it hurt her shin or
punched her in the face.
Well then she's going to have this
mental block in her head that she's not
gonna be able to overcome one day she's
going to get to be,
get to a point where I can light spar
with her.
She's not there.
Yeah,
I do think maybe she'll get there some
certain games play out differently.
Right?
I mean fun.
Like I'm not letting my seven year old
daughter score basket either.
Right.
But I probably wouldn't punch her in the
face.
Right,
right,
right.
I'm not letting her beat me in.
No,
you're not even letting her know.
That's fun.
I won't like snap her neck or rip your
throat out like yes.
Well what I do is like say like,
here's another example,
like if I'm rolling with a girl,
you know,
if you're a man is doing Jujitsu with a
girl.
Yeah.
If you're going full blast,
you're not getting anything out of it
either.
So what I do is if I'm sparring with a
girl,
I pretend that I'm only as strong as
them,
so if they're pushing against me instead
of going the fuck out of here and just
locking down and you know,
and giving them the full chimpanzee
strength I give,
I give with things.
So I don't,
I don't want to allow my body to use
full blast.
I understand.
So as they push I just give in and try
to use technique and find a better way
in,
you know,
I just try it out,
we'll try to go with it,
you know?
Yeah.
So yeah,
I let them score on me in that sense.
Like I'll let them get side control on
me.
And then I'll hit escape and try to get
back in,
but everything I do,
I do with almost no strength.
I just move my own body away.
I would tap them out in four seconds.
I just don't know any.
I understand.
Probably wouldn't by the way,
just because 99 percent of you don't
know me.
I wouldn't have done it at all.
I would've never even got in there.
I don't know that thing.
But if you did know that thing,
I think maybe you'd probably have a
different opinion on it.
Correct.
What I mean by that thing is if I like,
I'm either going to go in there and not
let the guy score or what would have
mostly likely happened is I wouldn't go
in the ring.
Whatever that ring is at all in the
first place.
I'm not trying to discourage.
No,
I know what you're playing.
Like.
Yeah.
I just think that when you're playing
basketball and you're playing basketball
with a small person,
that doesn't move as good as you.
You're trying to blow them out of just
knocking them by slamming,
slamming shit.
Put it if I can.
But if I can win 11 nothing and remind
them for the rest of their lives,
I'm interested in that.
So fine.
I don't know what else to say.
I understand what you're saying.
Dick.
Did the competition.
It's fun.
I enjoy it.
I'm not trying to hurt me.
Like I think there's two ways to build
the biggest building.
One,
just build the biggest building or to
tear everybody else's.
Building down.
No interest in hearing other people's
buildings.
But if I fucking build the biggest
building I'm letting you know.
And the same way that you should let me
know I'm not gonna cry about that,
but I love the game.
That's why I love business.
It's the one place you can do that
forever.
I agree with you,
but I just feel like physical things
that becomes a very to a different
place.
I'm not in rings and that gets into it.
Again,
in basketball,
like you run faster,
you'll feel very comfortable shutting
out my seven year old daughter and
basketball,
but I'm completely not comfortable
punching so you know.
I see what you're saying.
Yeah.
Let's let her score,
man.
Let her let her sneak through a little
bit.
Do you think the paper view of Mcgregor
Mayweather?
It's going to be because it's not just
not a debate anymore.
Hundred percent going to happen.
I don't know about that 100 percent
gonna happen.
No.
Putting it on tape right now might not
be right.
Well,
listen.
you know what?
Either build the biggest building or not
when I will have a nice little exchange
in 40 years.
You will.
You'll make fun of me.
You'll know you're close as clip.
It's happening.
Well,
I would say doing everything they can.
If you looked at it as in terms of a
zero percent chance to 100 percent
number,
I think we're in the seventies in the
seventies or eighties,
clarify because I think that's where
Brad as well.
I think there's a significant legal
hurdle to overcome with the UFC and they
might not.
Might not overcome that depending on how
they play that card.
This is my opinion on it.
Now.
Mcgregor has publicly stated that he
believes because of the Ali Act,
he can compete in boxing and not do it
with the UFC,
but he wants everything to be smooth so
he would rather have the UFC involved,
but he also wants the UFC to recognize
what he says is their place,
so there's mayweather productions,
the UFC and mcgregor productions,
so this is what he's promotions rather,
so this is what he is stating now he's
going to be a partner in the promotion
and so there's going to be some sort of
a negotiation for how things are split
up in three ways and then the question
becomes can can they work that out?
Okay.
If they can work that out,
then it becomes a question of should
they do it and will it be competitive
and is it good for their brand and
that's where they might have a debate on
this.
I think what's gonna end up happening is
the economics are going to be so big
that it's going to override the brand
play.
The the math is just going to be too
big.
It's possible,
but mcgregor so big.
The economics of him fighting and MMA
like see,
look at it this way.
So if he fights mayweather,
maybe there'll be 4 million pay per view
buys.
Right.
But it was packed.
What was Pacquiao mayweather before?
What was it,
Jamie?
Four and a half or something.
We looked at it the other day.
Just Google it.
Google it real quick.
I think it was like four and a half.
I think it was the biggest of all.
Four point six,
right?
Was it a four point six?
I think was the biggest of all.
Well,
we'll find out.
I think it was the biggest of all time.
And uh,
I think that,
that those numbers though,
here's the deal.
Mcgregor can do those numbers over the
course of three fights.
So is that a 44 point six?
So four point 6 million papers using now
mcgregor has done one point five for the
Nate Diaz rematch.
One point three for Eddie Alvarez.
Some.
Somewhere around those range.
So that right there,
just those two together.
A roughly $3 million pay per views for
to fight.
He making notes.
Fights.
Fuck load.
No,
no,
he's not going to make the kind of,
I mean not as not the same money he
would make as a co promoter,
but,
and,
and if he loses in a bat in a boxing
match,
it's so simple for him to say,
that's not what I do and go back.
That's true.
I don't know.
MMA,
the not even remotely close to you and
not enough to be dangerous here,
but what,
from what I understand,
I've done a little homework.
He doesn't have a lot of great natural
fights.
He's a third fight with Diaz.
Great natural fights.
These next three fights,
he's got a bunch.
So help me understand what like,
you know,
that's why I'm setting it up for you.
So from a financial standpoint,
from what the fans want,
right?
The champions underneath of it seems
like he's fought several of them.
He's one those pretty glaringly.
Cool.
What's the boy when the Nate Diaz fight
glaring?
The first one on the second one was a
very close decision.
I mean the other new ideas is the big
one is the big one.
So that one brings in close to 2 million
pay per view buys.
I really do.
I grieve ds three,
one point three and one point two,
one point five,
one point five and one point three,
three for Eddie Alvarez where he won his
second world title,
right?
The other one is tyron woodley or
whoever wins the tyron woodley versus
Stephen Wonderboy Thompson rematch for
170 pound title.
That's an interesting fight too,
because if it goes up and and challenges
at one 70 and winds that Jesus fucking
Christ,
now he's through the roof.
Now he's the biggest star in sports.
I mean he becomes this gigantic,
huge global worldwide phenomenon that's,
that's entirely inside the realm of
possibility.
Now he's not favored in a fight.
He gets 170 pound champion because the
guys are bigger,
they're faster or they're,
they're,
they're stronger rather.
But he's fast as fuck.
He's really clever.
He's very interesting.
The way he approached his fights,
he's,
he's very intelligent and it's not
outside the realm of possibility that he
could beat someone at 170 pounds that's
holding the world title,
whoever that is.
So that's a big fight too,
and that could also with him attached to
bring in one point five,
maybe 2 million pay per view buys.
So what you're talking about is in a
couple of fights he could make what he
could make in that one.
Floyd mayweather fight.
He wants to be a global icon.
There's no way.
Anything he does in just MMA trumps that
fight.
No,
no,
you're right.
You're right.
Because it's a short sentence.
It transcends the sport also.
It's a really good match for him because
mayweather doesn't really knock people
out.
I mean he knocked out Victor Ortiz,
Ortiz had his hands down.
Exactly.
He fucked up.
He headbutted him and then he was trying
to apologize and then may whether the
chaotic.
But that was a different sort of
scenario.
Before that.
The last guy,
I believe he stopped as Ricky Hatton and
he stumped.
Yeah,
11 or 12.
I mean he's in.
But by the way,
Ricky Hatton is like half the size of
conor mcgregor.
Conor mcgregor is a big guy.
He's tall.
He's five,
nine.
He's broad shouldered and he fights.
He can fight easily at one 70,
you know,
he cuts weight down to 1:55.
I'm in a fairly healthy manner.
Very unhealthy for him to get down to
1:45,
but he has done it.
If they fight,
I assume they're going to fight
somewhere in 155 pound range.
Connor will be significantly bigger than
anybody floyd's ever fought before.
What was your favorite sport growing up?
Martial arts growing up?
Yeah.
I was just like,
why?
It shouldn't definitely that Chuck
Norris Movies got me into it times for
sure.
Yeah,
there was that,
but there was also the finality of it
and also finish him.
Yeah.
Well it was just,
it was so real.
Like it didn't matter to me anymore.
Have a ball.
I love that.
The hat,
obviously a mortal Kombat the guy right
next to the guy had the hat,
like sliced you with the hat.
Random.
Someone's slice to mortal Kombat three
years.
Uh,
it just,
to me it was so much more dangerous.
It was so much more.
There's so much more on the line.
Or you'll fight fan like a boxing fan
too.
I've always described martial arts as
high level problem solving with dire
physical consequences.
That's what I looked at it.
Yeah.
It's just,
it's also your problem solving.
Someone who's improvising in the moment
with like.
And there's such a psychological factor
in why you like stand up to.
Yeah.
It's how I think about keynotes.
So what.
One of the reasons I think my speaking
career has gone so well is I'm reverse
engineering the crowd in realtime.
How so?
I'm literally give them the talk,
right?
Feeding off the reactions and navigating
in an Improv manner on my business
content.
Huh?
So you don't have a clear outline.
I have a clear outline for the first
seven minutes,
which is I already gave you that spiel.
I like to frame up my life.
I'm an immigrant,
made that little Schpeel I already gave
you.
That's all I've got.
And then I basically go into the state
of the union.
Okay.
So now if you're going to give a speech.
So if you're going to give
one of these keynotes,
what's your objective?
Like what are you trying to accomplish?
What are you doing that leg brand
legacy,
legacy.
I,
so I talk about stuff that most people
think is coming and I think it's
actually here and they don't think it's
real anything.
I'm a futurist or a or a destructor and
so I'll go and talk about instagram and
why I think people can go from zero to
$100 million in their business in seven
years or from zero to $100,000.
So the amount of people listening right
now that are making $81,000
a year doing something they hate that
could make $80,000
a year on instagram either selling
something or slowly but surely building
their brand and then doing content deals
is staggeringly practical.
How do people make money on instagram?
I don't make any money.
I have one point 8 million instagram
followers have made zero sense.
The way people make money,
the way people make money is always the
same.
So I would argue you do make money
because you're using a chest move
instead of transacting just on that
platform.
That is a platform where you create
reach and awareness that drives towards
things of this nature and then you
either sell advertising or get into
business development where you have
pieces of equity in businesses that you
build through the attention people sell
against the tension.
So either you're doing commercials or
you're doing step two,
which is you're building brand,
right?
So one thing I've never done is I've
never been paid ever for a piece of
content I put out on social,
which is the majority of how people get
paid,
but I get paid $100,000
to give a speech and I've done that
because of the attention and awareness
that I've been able to build on those
platforms.
Every book,
Mr.
Speeches,
speeches,
fuck this.
Fuck all this posts and pictures of my
food.
So do I think.
I think.
I think there's,
you know,
you could sell stuff right now I'm
obsessed with people buying and selling
shit.
I don't know if you know this,
but it is scary.
Scary how much money can be made if you
go to thrift stores and Marshall's and
dollar stores and garage sales.
And Flip Shit on craigslist.
Ebay let go.
Really?
And I mean real economics.
So people go to thrift stores,
they buy a bunch of vintage clothes and
then they go on craigslist.
It's even scarier than that.
Now that you have a phone and you get
the Ebay App and you just scan shit.
It's not even vintage clothes.
Which is like the thing that most people
listening think makes sense.
It's fucking every single thing on
earth.
Every single person right now that's
listening,
that's needs $5,000.
It's in your fucking house.
It's in your closet,
it's in your basement,
it's in your attic.
Your shit that you're not using is worth
money and you just don't want to put in
the work.
The flip it,
Huh?
Uh Huh.
So I started something called the 2017
flip challenge,
right?
And I made this video and the amount of.
I'm getting hundreds of emails a week of
people like,
Holy Shit.
I was on fucking welfare.
I have college loans.
I wanted to take my family on a
vacation.
And it was the fucking fourth pair of
shoes in my closet that I didn't have.
Or people that are not as fortunate
maybe really don't have a lot of stuff
in their home.
They were just going to dollar stores or
thrift store scanning with the Ebay APP.
One guy found some guy just bought like
80,000
fucking American apparel tee shirts for
$80,
forty nine cents.
And it's like selling them for like 16
bucks on Ebay.
Like it's the flip man.
I'm telling you,
the reason I'm saying this right now is
I want somebody to leave with something
tangible from us.
They're paying for themselves.
The flip,
like all this fucking shit here.
Like I'm looking.
Yeah,
I'm looking at him like that.
Big things.
Probably 11 and this fucking Buddha.
So for 11 bucks,
you think that's worth way more than
that respect,
you know.
But like,
you know what the plan is to sell that
guy,
makes those.
He actually sculpt them and then makes a
mold of the sculpture and then sends
them out.
They're dope.
And the sunglasses actually come off.
A biggie.
His eyes,
his details in his eyes,
smoking dope,
and then we've got a condom.
Mcgregor one here and the Tupac.
One couple of bliss.
Plastisol guy's a bad motherfucker.
So Joe on this thing.
Seriously,
it's.
I'm fascinated by this.
By what?
This weapon flipping shit.
Yeah.
I'm fat because you understand because
of the content I put out,
I get asked a thousand times a week
through social email live streams.
How do I start?
I need money.
How do I raise money from venture
capitalists?
I'm like,
you don't.
You're not raising money from venture
capitalist lets you know you're not
fucking like at 98 point nine percent of
the people are not raising money from
venture capitalists.
Invest.
You're not inventing the next instagram.
Let's get a lot more fucking practical
and like start like learning how to
actually make money and then take that
money and if you want to go build an
APP,
would that money Mazal Tov.
But learn how to actually make the
money.
And the flip thing has been,
I'd be putting out business content for
a long time.
It's been the one thing that I'm
watching people actually pull off.
Hm.
That's a really interesting perspective
because you're talking about something
that's very practical,
like somebody can actually get going on
that books.
You know,
like when someone comes to you and says,
I want to start the new facebook,
you're like,
well good luck.
Yeah,
that's been,
you know this.
They just think immediately they're
going to be able to start to see match
come up and you're like,
Hey,
I'm starting this business.
It's going to be like it's gonna be for
UFC fighters if they want.
If you.
Yeah,
you get pitched $25 and invest in
businesses.
I fucking believe in let alone ones that
you don't exactly like.
I've had people come up to me that have
like super solid businesses that are
really.
I think what they're doing is awesome.
Have you ever passed anything that's
gone on to be like monster?
What?
Oh,
I'm not interested.
I don't.
I'm not.
I'm just not interested.
To me.
I mean obviously I have a very different
life than you do in terms of like that
is what you do.
You're about.
Because I'm not,
that's not what I do,
so for me,
anything that takes away from my time is
that thinking.
Yeah.
Normally,
like people say,
well you don't want to,
you want to have to do anything.
You just invest it like,
no,
you don't.
No,
you don't understand because then I'm
gonna think about it and that's very
valuable.
My thoughts and having that resource
occupied by anything that in is you are
doing something,
they're leveraging your name and now
you're associated with it and you've got
and you care about your name.
Yeah.
And like there's definitely that.
I mean that's what you mean.
Even if my name wasn't associated with
it,
if it was just they were just using my
money,
I just,
I don't want to think like I have a
limit.
Yeah.
Well I have too much shit I'm already
thinking about.
It's not less thinking.
My thinking is over.
Yeah,
exactly.
I avoid anything new just simply because
I get obsessed with things.
I don't have the time I get it.
Yeah.
What's the last thing you got obsessed
with?
Archery.
Bowhunting?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Have you been doing.
Trust me,
five years,
45 years,
and continue to get worse with less than
five years.
Four and a half years hunting,
three years.
Bowhunting.
What are you obsessed with you pussy.
Basketball.
He loved me.
Like honestly,
I've been for the last little bit last
year.
It's honestly what you like,
what you talk about,
but not.
I haven't been following you for the
last year.
I've been following you since you run
diggnation a long time.
Oh yeah.
By the way,
Jamie's the first person to tell me
about.
You initially talked to you about about
him too.
Like twice and then I got an email from
your guy like serendipitous asleep,
but a content and different things.
Pattern recognition to.
I'm just trying to figure out all this
stuff almost because I was five,
10 years ago.
I wanted to be Zuckerberg,
instagram,
all of that stuff and I know now it's
not there.
I'm doing a different job and you know
what's interesting about that?
The thing that has really come to the
top and my content that's really also
helping people.
Self awareness.
One thing I'm enjoying listening to you,
I'm like,
this guy really like you can just like a
martial art.
It's been really interesting.
I'm sitting here kind of thinking.
I'm like,
wow,
there's some real self awareness going
on here and even just thinking about you
now saying that I wish I could figure
out,
forget about drug to make your Dick
Bigger.
If I could give somebody a pill that
would allow them to deploy self
awareness,
the amount of happiness that would be
going on in this world would be
tremendous.
I I understand that.
I can give them a solution struggle and
overcoming obstacles and very difficult
problems to solve problem solving,
whether it's through martial arts or
even through complicated things that
don't seem complicated like yoga,
very difficult tasks teach you about
yourself.
Those things teach you about personal
awareness.
Let's let's take a step back amount of
people that when they do that and fail,
right,
decide to spend all their fucking time
on pondering and blaming is unbelievably
high.
Well,
that's just a problem with the way their
mind is structured.
Let's just consciousness structuring.
Hence why I'm interested in that self
awareness pill and slash or populating
this conversation to the top because
when you start caring about what you are
versus what you're not good shit
happens.
Right?
Well,
yeah,
exactly.
Or you know,
I assume when I think about Larry
Holmes,
like I had a conversation once about
like how the Jab that he was deceased in
assassin.
Man,
it's really interesting when you start
tripling down in your strengths,
obviously you have to round yourself
out.
You don't want to get exposed,
especially in mma.
Obviously it's so multidimensional that
way,
um,
that it becomes a vulnerability.
But fuck man,
I'm big on tripling down on people's
strengths.
Yeah,
it's huge.
Well,
the,
one of the interesting things about mma
is people that you call specialists,
like there's a few people that are
really good at one aspect of MMA and
they dominate people because of that.
Like Anderson Silva is the greatest
martial artist of all time was just a
sensational striker.
And when you,
every fight starts off standing.
You had to deal with his striking before
you could get to him before you could
take him down,
before he could try to submit him
through that.
He had to get through that and that was
a.
he's a specialist.
Damien Maia is a specialist in a
completely different ways.
One of the top welterweight contenders,
probably number one now next to a
wonderboy was going to be fighting for a
rematch,
the title,
but Damien Maia is a pure Jujitsu
specialists.
His striking is only to get close enough
to you to grab you dragged to the
ground,
strangle you,
and in that way he's a lot of a lot of
what he is as a throwback,
but his jujitsu skill is so elite that
everyone else who goes to the ground
with him.
Even guys like Carlos Condit who was a
former world champion to really high
level guy,
just get smushed like a bug and
strangled because he's such a
specialist.
I get it.
Yeah,
it's martial arts is very interesting in
that way because that works with some
people,
but it doesn't work with other people
and other people have beaten.
Damien Maia,
because of the fact that in many ways
one dimensional,
but that one dimension is a motherfucker
of a dementia.
I'm.
I'm a big boxing fan.
I grew up a big Aaron Pryor family to a
big pernell whitaker fan.
Like what was in that bottle?
Man?
Louis,
what the fuck did he slip them?
What did he slip them?
I'm dying to know.
I would like to know Panama Lewis is
still alive.
I'm able to.
I'm able to quantify that because I
think about a lot of the boxers who had
their one or two things.
Then it was just fascinating.
Sure.
Like had to figure it out.
Jones Rojo.
You know,
it's funny you're talking about Condo,
like when Roy Jones found his moment to
go up to heavyweight.
Interesting.
Okay.
Well,
here's a perfect example.
We were talking about steroids.
Yes.
When Roy Jones went up to fight John
Ruiz,
I don't know.
Roy Dot well.
I've met him.
He's a great guy.
I'm a huge fan.
He's probably one of my favorite boxers,
if not my favorite of all.
Time was great,
but I'm pretty sure he did some Mexican
supplements to fight John Ruiz to get up
to that way.
He was 200 pounds.
He was jacked.
He was shredded.
It's not necessarily that natural for
you to put on that kind of weight in
that short period of one slash 68 to one
slash 75 to 200.
That's a big.
That's a lot of CIG jumping and looked
amazing and you know,
kept a speed.
Then here's the thing,
dropped back down to one 75 again to
fight tarver and looked like shit.
Yeah.
Had a really hard time making the way
and I think also you look at his body
who was smooth,
his muscle tone was different.
It didn't look the same and I think a
lot of that is endocrine system
potentially suffering from the steroids,
like taking steroids and then the crash,
I don't know,
this is pure speculation,
but all my years of seeing people do the
same thing,
seeing people take steroids or take
anything that any anabolic enhancements
and then dropping down and getting off
of them.
Again,
you just,
you've seen flat pattern recognition.
Well,
I know a lot of pattern recognition
about fighting.
I,
that's one of the things about fighting
is pattern chunking.
You know,
you see things that you've seen before,
you know,
and you,
you see it coming before maybe even the
other guy sees it coming and that's what
I do with consumer behavior and that's
how I bet on business.
That makes sense.
I was an early investor in facebook and
Tumblr and twitter.
It was because I just knew that that
looked to me like email.
That looked to me like I saw that I
invested in twitter because I thought it
was the next email.
What do you think of snapchat?
So I invest at a first full,
full disclosure.
I wrote a $5,000,000
check into snapchat,
snapchat,
snapchat.
That you're responsible for those puppy
dog filters.
That shit's got to stop.
But ladies,
listen to me.
Stop taking pictures with the puppy dog
nose stop.
I like it.
I think more the don't.
Don't listen to me.
I'm just fucking around.
Do whatever you want to do.
The flowers on the head though aren't
making it look any better yet is it
gives you a coachella.
It's fake.
They're fake flowers or think you're
crazy person.
They do that or should they put the
check?
No,
they should definitely take flowers to
figure out the next move because
instagram's features have in the short
term affected it and where snapchat was
on the verge of becoming a monster was
we started seeing 40 and 50 year olds
download it.
The features came to instagram.
It gave those 45 year olds a reason not
to download another APP and that's why
snapchat's lost a little momentum.
It's not that a 20 year old.
Yes.
Some are using stories more than
instagram now.
It wasn't like a mass exodus of that.
It was the growth that they were
feeling.
Forty and 50 year olds that were just
starting just like facebook back in
2000,
10,
11.
They just started getting your aunt that
wanted to act like she was in it
starting to download and then the
network effect because her aunt has a
friend and that's what happens.
It stopped that and that is the concern
that snapchat has,
which is in wants to be at full scale
because that's how you justify a
$20,000,000,000
valuation,
which is what it wants to go IPO at.
I think snapchat's big things.
The filters like the Zombie filter in
the rainbow throw up all that stuff.
Like that's what makes it cool and the
fact that I could take your face and put
her on my face,
like that's kind of dope.
I mean a lot of people do that and it's
really pretty amazing.
If your face is similar,
like similar sized,
what you can pull off.
It's amazing.
I agree.
I mean,
listen,
they've done a lot of smart stuff,
especially with ar and all that kind of
stuff.
It's gonna be very fascinating.
If the glasses take off at full
scale or what else are they up to?
They call themselves snap now.
I've never seen a snapchat anymore as a
company.
Their snapchat,
but as a holding company,
corporate bullshit.
Nobody cares about.
The reason I care is when they came out
with the glasses speckles I,
I've never seen a social network act
like a fashion brand.
There's something different about
snapchat that way.
How's it act like a fashion brand?
Because the glass is like if you said if
I woke up tomorrow and found out that
snapchat was coming out with sneakers,
I'd be like [inaudible],
where's.
That would make no sense for twitter or
instagram or facebook.
Huh?
So that's where I'm curious if they're
opening up that avenue.
Snap is very la out.
It is not hardcore silicon valley
product.
It's got a little that La Flavor.
Evan's got that.
What's the difference?
The difference is Silicon Valley is very
tech nerded out.
It's a little different now because
everybody's gone there to make their
millions,
but it is still very grounded in
technology.
Engineers are the rock stars and it's a
San Francisco vibe.
Snapchat is an La company and it started
by a very young entrepreneur who is way
cooler than the majority of
entrepreneurs that we've seen before.
Build these products just in life.
He was a cooler kid and the vibe of the
product that the exclusiveness of it,
the awkwardness abusing it and they like
that.
It's like,
if you don't understand us,
fuck you.
It had that vibe and so I'm curious to
see how that plays out.
Yeah.
I don't use it.
I have it on my phone.
I use instagram and twitter and facebook
and facebook.
Honestly,
I kind of use facebook only because
instagram links up to it.
I don't,
but it's interesting like distribution.
Yeah.
I'd use it and I don't interact with
people that much on facebook and people
get mad,
but this don't have that much time.
That is native to interact there.
Right.
It's a lot easier to interact in an on a
twitter.
Twitter's easiest.
Fuck.
Instagram's a little weirder because
like when you get a comment,
if you reply to that comment,
then you have to go find the original
comment.
It's not a native.
It's clunkier.
Twitter is the watercooler of our
society.
It's got a lot of shortcomings for
content and how much people are paying
attention to the newsfeed,
but definitely from a conversation
standpoint there's nothing close.
So for example,
when this airs,
like that's where I'll go and engage
with people because a lot of people have
never heard of me before that,
listen to this and I'll respond to those
feedbacks much more data than anyone
else.
Yeah,
I will too.
And that's where I have the most
followers too and I will interact with
people more,
but I also feel like I said,
I just think that Jamie was just telling
me the other day that a instagram makes
it so you can like people's comments
now.
Yes.
That's a new little feature.
They've,
they've been,
as you know,
Jim,
it sounds like you're really getting
deeper and deeper in this game.
Like they've been innovating very fast.
Tons,
tons.
Snapchat today put out a way for you to
link out to websites.
So there's just movement.
There's always moving.
Facebook is definitely gonna launch
stories in facebook.
Yeah,
because yeah,
they just launched it in Ireland,
so I've already seen the preview of it.
It's out like it,
so that's coming,
so that will be interesting to see what
that does.
So plenty more to come.
I think facebook should become a
television company like I think they
should actually come out with a
television and then I think when you're
in an actual towe have an actual
physical television.
This is just what I think they should
do.
And when you're in your feed you see
something,
you just flick it and it goes on your
television,
you watch it.
So like apple TV does.
Hmm.
Don't do that.
Facebook,
facebook,
listen to me.
If you want to talk about fighting
somebody.
Facebook,
if you want to fight for job,
no one's going to buy your fucking TV.
You're got to make a lot of TVS.
They're going to be sitting in a
warehouse somewhere.
Can we?
The mistake I made that mistake,
the TV I'm going to say,
and in this keynote,
look at this great clip from 2017 when I
fully predicted the facebook TV.
I just.
Why would they get involved in selling
tvs?
What would it be different than their
TV?
And you own the hardware,
you own the action.
Why would anybody buy that when you
could do like a little google chrome
thing that sticks right into a Usb port
and just shoot it right from your
android phone and TV and make the best
product.
Everybody has permission to play in
anybody space.
So if you make the best tv,
Sony had no permission to go in the
video game space until they made the
fucking playstation.
Everybody's like,
what the fuck?
Right?
Like Netflix wasn't supposed to produce
the best original content,
but that's a difference,
right?
Like there's a platform,
if you're selling a console that makes
video games,
then you have to hire a bunch of people
to make games for that.
Or you're the razor and the razor blade
thing,
right?
Like facebook and just first of all,
razor and razor blade.
Would it be.
And you just become the platform.
Other people can make it like Sony,
Sony to make those games.
Right.
But they hired people to.
They made some of their own game and
mainly bought from other professors,
but more importantly they created a
platform that people built for that
facebook has facebook can go out and buy
the number for TB manufacturer steel to
people from Samsung and they're in the
fucking game.
Right.
But everybody already has a TV like
getting them to buy a facebook tv one
more time and you know this Joe,
like we used to have Sony Tvs.
Now we have Samsung.
People like Jamie,
you with me on this now he's with me
with both of you.
I mean,
I see what you're both saying.
Both of you.
You know,
I'm leaving Jamie,
Jamie,
Jamie.
This is historic.
He also knows that I'm not connected
directly.
Correct.
Yeah,
that's a great point because I.
I mean you brought up that snapchat
sneaker thing a few weeks ago.
At least.
That's what I saw with a few weeks ago
and I think that's a great point.
It's not gonna work for everyone.
Good idea if you want to go broke,
but it's a,
it's a brand thing like put all your
money and you know what's interesting is
actually where I was about to go.
You just walked into it.
I'm fascinated by the following,
the fact that you even said easy's three
years ago,
right?
Everybody,
you would have never said anything to
understand us.
The reason why I say because he buys
easiest and mock him on a daily basis,
but what are the shittiest fucking goofy
look at sneakers I've ever seen in my
life and and they sell it crazy.
God,
there's a lot of retards out there.
Hey Joe,
how about this?
What I'm of the age then when,
when you have ceased started when mixed
martial arts started hitting the scene,
right?
Royce Gracie,
like way back.
It feels like.
So I apologize.
So you know,
what did everybody say about that?
No chance.
Fucking stupid.
Well,
that's different.
No,
it's not sure.
It is at the.
Everybody understood that fighting at
the fashion is primal.
It's the way we express.
These are definitely not private.
Brother yeezys are primal.
That's stupid.
Stripe and color.
Stripe on the side of Christ makes them
harder to duplicate.
They look like shit wrong.
Trust me.
Five years from now,
you're gonna making fun of those things.
Hang in there buddy.
On my feet right now.
Those are pretty dope.
Been retroed like four or five times and
that's where those sell for $700 and
they're like $160.
Shoes and those look better.
Those are Jordan's.
They look cool.
I've never wore a pair of Jordans my
life.
Really?
Michael Jordan with my entire heart.
Whoa.
I'm a 41 year old knicks fan.
Just a one year old knicks fan out there
right now.
Fuck you.
If you bought Jordan's,
can't believe what you're saying.
Yep.
Stop the next championships.
That's right.
So,
so you're just a loyal because he's a
really good basketball player.
You're loyal to the team that he crushed
you.
Loyal to his characteristics that you
admire and you do on your own daughter.
Yes.
I respect.
I,
I fully respect that.
I respect and understand he's the
greatest basketball player of all time.
Right?
Is he still,
is that still a jam?
That is probably right.
I mean,
listen,
you want to get into the Wilton,
there's some different ways to the bait
that.
Here's what I will say.
You can say I hate when people argue
with me on this.
You can separate respecting somebody's
skillset and thinking they're a piece of
fucking shit,
but you only thing he's a piece of shit
because he beat your team.
Yes,
that's it.
Isn't that more than a fuck enough?
I guess.
See Tom Brady choke would be
phenomenally happy with that.
If he died.
Listen,
I don't want to go there because I could
never put it again right after Sunday.
I'd be real happy.
Real fucking happy.
You just don't like that.
He's really good and he wins.
Correct.
That's so weird.
Expensive.
My team see that,
but that whole my team,
I.
I understand if you own that team,
but you don't own it yet.
No,
it's my escape,
Joe.
It's the one place I get to escape.
It's my three hours fucking 16 times a
year where I can recalibrate my whole
fucking insane life.
Well,
I'm coming in from a perspective of
weird perspective as a person who is a
sports fan because my sports that I only
watch her martial arts and as a fan of
them,
I'm a fan of performance more than I'm a
fan of a person,
so I'm not a fan.
Like when I watch people fight,
I'm a fan of whoever wins the fight.
I'm a fan of how they win it.
I'm a fan of what goes down.
Not a bandwagon.
I'm kidding.
I'm a fan of technique.
You love the craft.
I love the craft and I also love.
I love moments.
I love someone dominating a moment.
That is exactly right.
And I love when I don't have a horse in
the race,
so you always have a horse race when it
comes to the ball and football and I
used to in hockey and baseball,
but my teams won championships and then
I get out.
All right,
so you can if so,
no baseball.
So if you could appreciate someone who's
a bad motherfucker,
breaks the home run record.
That stuff I get excited about.
That's why I love that.
That's what I liked.
I liked boxing so much for that.
I tend not to have a horse in the race.
I usually root for the underdog.
That's a good move.
Yeah.
It feels better when they win.
That's usually my default.
Yeah.
When you.
When someone is the favorite and they
beat the shit out of,
so I'm going to go.
Well,
I saw that coming when Tyson was in his
prime.
Those were weird fights because they
were an execution fibrous cells and
those were real event.
Bruce Allen was post was posted by the
way.
Bruce Selden had,
uh,
no,
that's smoke smoking.
Burke Cooper,
who I think of when I think about bruce
selling because they had a similar body
shape,
jacked smoking.
Burke Cooper,
knockdown holyfield in Atlanta.
Yeah.
And I thought he had that excited.
That's great.
Fine.
Holyfield.
Yeah.
I mean there's a lot of great boxers,
but Tyson had something going on where
pop culture.
Yeah,
it was an executioner.
Yeah.
It's popcorn when they transcend into
popcorn.
The problem with that a lot of times is
I feel bad for those,
Rhonda.
Right.
Like the drop off is so extreme when you
get to become a cultural icon.
Yeah,
but she's a real weird case because
she's essentially done so you gotta
wonder like her mindset when she was
winning was this mindset of a destroyer.
She would go in there and smash these
girls and she was all in,
but then she got wooed by Hollywood and
all the distractions and movies and TV
shows and all that nonsense and then
bought into a bad strategy against one
of the best strikers in the sport and
fought the absolute worst way she could
have fought against that elite striker
and got fucked up and once she got
fucked up,
man the wheels came off.
She takes a whole year off and then
comes back again and just gets
annihilated and now dilated and now
she's essentially done.
Here's my biggest crazy mma in the
modern world [inaudible],
you lose the entire fight in within the
time of an instagram post.
You're in deep shit.
You are,
but you're not.
See,
because she beat cats in Ghana in 14
seconds and cat Zingano is still in the
mix and mma,
math is all fucked up,
but it doesn't really work this way,
but this is a fact.
Cat Zingano stopped.
Amanda Nunez,
she beat her in the third round,
but Ronda Rousey after that fight arm
barred cat Zingano in 14 seconds,
so I get those banana.
What's really cool about Emma,
I have said this,
you may have caught the shame.
It's the closest thing to
entrepreneurship because everybody loses
an entrepreneurship boxing's.
Funny.
That loss really dangles.
It's devastating that loss.
I've been more fascinated from afar and
I'm not as deep into sport,
and you can correct me if I'm wrong,
but there is an absolute different level
because the way the sport is structured,
there's an acceptance by the fan base of
the loss in this sport that I think is
very different than boxing.
It's like it's a scarlet letter of
boxing.
When you're coming up,
you need to keep it clean,
right?
You want to be undefeated and want to be
an undefeated contender.
It has a is a big factor and an MMA
almost.
No one is undefeated except number man
off.
He's one of the very few guys that's a
top contender right now.
That's undefeated and he's just a
destroyer,
but you know he's rare.
He's.
He's very rare.
Most people at the top have lost a
couple of times what connor showed when
he lost,
he showed the ability to regroup,
take it on the chin like a fucking man.
Make no excuses whatsoever and jump
right back in and when,
and that's super,
super rare.
He's a phenomenal individual in his
ability to visualize things.
His belief in himself is just
unflappable and his incredible
confidence and ability to operate under
pressure.
That's the big thing,
is being dwarfed by the moment,
by the moment happened so many times,
so much.
People let allow those negative thoughts
to creep into their mind.
All those eyeballs.
It's all fucking eyeballs,
baby.
A lot of eyeballs and a lot of doubt.
What was the.
What was the biggest audience you
performed?
What was the first time you took a
quantum jump?
Like what was the number?
Did he go from like consistently doing
like clubs?
Then what was the first time like?
What was that?
Because I had a very weird thing
happened to me with speaking.
It was always like 500,
349 and then I got this weird Gig for
remax natural national convention at the
Mgm Grand,
like 15,000
Jesus Christ.
And I was like,
it was such a like.
I mean,
I would do it everyday if I could.
It seems really bizarre,
right?
Like that's a yes,
but I focused on the people that were
closest to me.
Okay.
It worked for me.
Yeah.
That's a good move.
That's the way to do it.
And while taking into account all the
people that aren't right there.
Yeah.
What about for you?
What was the uh,
well,
I mostly started out with clubs for a
long time,
mostly did clubs.
And then as I started getting more and
more popular,
I moved into larger places and the
biggest place that I've ever sold out
was in Denver,
which was like 5,700
people.
So that's a different experience,
man.
It's just weird.
It's weird.
Someone's addicted to their phones.
Do you have another meeting tonight?
What are you doing tonight?
Doing a Biz Dev meeting.
Really Your Business Development meeting
tonight at after 10:00
PM.
That's hilarious.
I,
I normally.
And you live in New York.
So this is 1:00
AM for you.
And I left at 4:00
AM this morning cause that's Chicago
meeting soon.
And speed.
What are you doing?
My brother still has a weird.
No,
I'm like seriously?
What was super cool?
I have,
I've never even tried smoking a
cigarette.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Well that's good.
Smoking cigarettes pot.
No.
Nothing.
No,
no,
no much district rent of every one of my
friends.
And maybe make you a little bit more
creative.
Uh,
I just think I have natural something
because my brother literally thinks I'm
a robot.
Like literally as asked weird questions
and passionate.
If you're passionate,
you're engaged.
If you're engaged,
you're excited.
You know what I am energy grateful as
fuck.
Well that's good.
Like if you really asked me what the
slight variation of that is,
I think it's gratitude.
Gratitude is huge.
I think gratitude is a real drug,
but I think it is too,
so I'm just grateful,
but certainly fuel its energy and its
uh,
its warmth and feeling also that's very
attractive.
Like other people recognize true
gratitude and they get excited by it
too.
Yeah.
And perspective.
I think perspectives that other one.
Oh,
I agree.
Yeah.
Perspective is good,
you know,
being honest and humble and recognizing
that yeah,
you work hard.
Yeah.
You bust your ass.
But yeah,
you're also like super lucky just to be
living in America for super lucky to be
held into one.
Yeah.
Your Dad might've decided to jerk off
one more time the day before.
Right.
And we wouldn't be here.
Damn.
400 Janie.
Your mom might've wanted to take a quick
glass of wine,
like 400 trillion to one.
The odds of being a human being.
No,
seriously.
This is a little weird thing,
but like we're going down this path,
like I'm fascinated by that.
Yeah.
No,
it's real.
It's a real statistic.
If you think about,
come really start dividing and
conquering.
Understand that you can end up on your
dad's.
Come instead or Napkin instead of
becoming a human trait.
It's humbling.
Yeah,
it is a lot of ways.
Yeah.
But once that happens,
once you become a human,
then even then the odds of being
fortunate to have good health,
fortunate to not have been,
have the fuck beat out of your body,
your parents,
or being in foster care with abusive
people or a million different factors
going down.
You're going down the path that I think
about on a daily basis.
I also had the misfortune of three of my
four grandparents dying before I knew
them because everybody died in Russia
and in their fifties because everybody's
fucking miserable from communism.
And then,
uh,
so I haven't had a whole lot of death in
my family.
Like I had A.
I mean,
it's real good.
So I'm grateful.
Gratitude is giant man.
It's really good.
And you know what?
And you can extend that gratitude.
Like there's a lot of people that woe is
me,
but God damn it.
You just need to look at,
look at it in a balanced perspective.
There are people in parts of the world
that would fucking literally kill to be
in any position that anyone listening to
this who is woe is me right now.
You know the problem with what was me?
Nobody's fucking listening.
My friends.
Let me tell you who's listening to you
complain either the two or three people
that kind of have to because they're
your parents or your other fucking
losing
friends.
Nobody gives a fuck.
That's the problem when people don't
understand about complaining isn't as
zero Roi and also excuses.
Excuses are terrible.
They're the worst thing you could ever
do is give yourself a reason why you're
not successful or not happy or not this
or not.
That was easy for you to say,
Gary.
Yeah,
because yeah,
your dad,
your dad's wine store,
Bro.
Fucking and here so happy.
He started fucking youtube channel.
Who will mud flaps to hit me with a belt
if anybody's made it.
That looks like you.
That's it.
So it must have happened.
There's a blueprint,
so I get it,
man.
Let's.
What is even making it right?
Well,
that's your.
Is Anybody happy?
That's it.
Are you,
is anybody that's in similar
circumstances,
did they navigate their way better than
you learn from them?
Learn from them?
I think for me the journey is the FEC
and addiction,
so he just loved the whole hustle of it
all the game,
you know?
It's funny.
I was listening to you about like
fighting and the performance.
That's how I feel about business.
Actually.
Buying the jets is going to be the worst
day of my life because then you're gonna
need a new mountain to climb.
Yeah.
Started started crunching.
I don't want that shit.
You know what I want?
I want to.
I want to build a honey empire.
Honey.
Honey,
I want to be able to bs.
I want to build one of the most
successful business things ever and I
want to do it in a way that I treated my
employees and my business partners in a
honey manner.
Oh,
okay.
Not actual honey.
No.
Honey like honey and vinegar or honey
than vinegar.
Right?
Correct.
Right.
You get more.
I was super pissed when Steve jobs was
the icon in Silicon Valley and all my
young friends started becoming dicks to
their employees because they thought
they were getting more out of their
employees that way about him to
narrative.
I fucking hate that,
but I wish I knew what the actual truth
was.
I wish I got to see him communicate with
his employees and see what it was that
freaked them out.
Like was he really a dick or did he work
with a bunch of ne'er?
Do Wells are lazy people were fools or
you know what it is?
Is it number one?
Why he wanted to be number one?
For sure he was a dick.
He was definitely Dick.
Listen,
truth is back to the way you talk about
steroid Houston,
hugh,
and I don't know.
Right?
I don't know her hard when a whole lot
of human beings are saying it.
Who worked for him?
Yeah,
I think he was absolutely completely
obsessed and I think for a lot of people
that really wasn't what they wanted.
They wanted a job,
you know,
they want us to do good at their jobs,
but I deploy empathy.
I know that other people have other
goals and wants and needs and that
shouldn't come.
Mine mine,
even though it's my company,
it shouldn't come at their expense.
It's my job as a leader to figure out
how to provide for them and figure out
what's left for me to do what I do.
That's leverage,
right?
But what he wanted to do was create
something unbelievably powerful and you
had this supervision of it and he wanted
everybody else to share that vision but
not really necessarily share in the
rewards of it,
which is a big problem,
right?
Less.
Listen,
I am known.
I don't know shit about him to critique
it.
Here's what I know.
I don't like turtlenecks ready for this.
Ready for this bottom line is he
impacted an entire generation of young
25 year old silicon valley ceos who
weren't smart enough and decided just to
be assholes across the board for like
two years there and it really suck.
So you would know that.
I don't know anything about that.
So explain to me what that was like
because I'm just your,
your miters we'll be talking to someone
from another country,
that whole era of like web two point.
Oh that second wave,
that 2004 that Kevin Rose,
right.
You know,
who invented dig then you know,
and xbox and Ed Williams and the
investors Soka and all these characters.
It was just a crazy thing.
You knew he were sitting in again,
it was kind of like hip hop,
85.
Like I would go to these meetings,
I would be in San Francisco,
I would hang out with them and I just
fucking knew I even have videos in 2009
like saying this ship and just knew I
was like,
these are going to be the fucking
fucking characters that are going to be
the next icons of the world because
they're building the products that
everybody's going to pay attention to.
And there were just a lot of things
going on.
At first it was pure shit.
Like these kids really just wanted to
save the world,
right?
Like let's make the world better with
technology than they started having
assholes.
Like me come in who had commerce
ambition and I'm like,
yes,
you save the world,
but let me own 10 percent of the company
while you save the moral.
Right.
And then you had the worst wave,
which was the people who blindly just
thought because they were 22 and wore a
hoodie that they were going to invent
the next facebook.
Yeah.
There's a lot of posers,
right?
You understand that there's a very big
difference between being an entrepreneur
and being a successful entrepreneur,
right?
Yeah.
But the market right now,
everyone's like,
oh,
you're a CEO and entrepreneur.
Like,
like as if you won.
That's like me saying,
I'm a basketball player.
I play basketball,
mom,
I'm not making any fucking money.
Right?
And so yeah,
we have a real issue in fake
entrepreneurship right now.
Everybody thinks,
you know,
it's cool.
It became cool.
It's crazy to me how cool
entrepreneurship became when I was a
kid.
Being an entrepreneur meant you were a
loser and had an idea.
You know,
you're laughing because a lot of
youngsters will listen.
You don't know.
Back in our day,
like entrepreneur was a word that you
rarely heard.
I used to think I was a businessman.
That's what I said,
not an entrepreneur.
You must hear a lot of really shitty
ideas for living for a living because I
get some email sometime and I'll get
like one paragraph and I'll get the fuck
outta here.
What is this nonsense?
And I just deleted.
But you must get that like all day long,
all day long.
It's hard to separate,
right?
Like how do you find those little
diamonds?
Sometimes you do and sometimes you
don't.
You have to take your ls.
I have an email that I always look at
from a good guy named Joe and he worked
at a company called air bed and
breakfast.
Joe At air bed and breakfast.
Gary Vee were huge fans here at our
company.
We'd love for you to never even replied.
Now airbnb is worth a lot of money.
Fucking money.
Email for my boy.
Ben Layer,
founder of thrillist.
Send me an email like,
hey,
I really like these guys.
You should look at it.
Didn't jump on it or be Parker big glass
company,
you know,
like it happens.
That's a weird one.
Right?
Who saw that?
A glasses company was going to be giant,
but other times you know Venmo.
Zappos knew it right away.
Like,
you know,
it happens.
I mean it goes both ways.
I saw Amazon.com.
I was like,
bitch,
how much money you gonna make selling
books?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
I use it every day.
I'm from the generation where people
made fun of my dad for because I didn't
open a second wine store and I went on
the Internet.
The Internet's youngsters.
Listen real quick.
People debated the Internet itself.
Forget about.
Is snapchat going to be here in five
years?
Back in 1994.
Five,
six,
seven,
eight.
People like the Internet not going to be
here in five years.
Go earlier than that.
When ibm first came out with their home
computer thing,
that's ridiculous.
Of course,
that's a joke.
Telephone is not a viable product.
One said.
Yeah.
By the people that didn't want the
telephone to win,
nobody saw a lot of things coming.
So what should we do,
Gary Vee?
What's wrap this up?
What should we do?
What should people do?
People should fucking stop complaining,
right?
People should figure out how the fuck
they are.
Good people should not listen to
America.
Propaganda of fixing the shit they suck
at.
They should be tripling down on what
they're good at.
They should be competent in certain
areas,
but you're not gonna become beyonce or
your bone structure is a certain way
like you're not going to solve
everything.
Your Iq can get a little bit better,
but don't worry about the incremental.
Figure out what you fucking puts you on
fire and you're halfway decent at.
If you're lucky enough right now to be
listening and you're good at what you
like become tunnel fucking vision
because there's way too many voices
telling you what and how.
And here's the other thing,
and this is the big one job,
because you have a humongous audience.
The biggest thing that I've seen
dividends from have the conversation
with the person that's holding you back.
The reason most people who are listening
right now are not doing that thing is
they're worried about the opinion of
somebody,
usually their mother,
usually their father,
and the reality is is that your spouse
may be the person holding you back and
you have to have that conversation.
Turn them off.
We have to get to a place where you're
doing you because the number one thing
that scares the fuck out of me is
regret,
and you're gonna.
Sit there at 72 and I'm going to say,
I wish I wish,
I wish,
and whether that's money or spend more
time with your family.
There's a million ways to do this.
Not everybody wants to buy the jets.
Not everybody wants to smoke weed on the
beach and Bahamas,
like everybody's got a different fucking
thing.
Figured out what your fucking thing is
and stop making fucking bullshit excuses
who the president is.
Your mom did this like,
like,
I missed it.
You had that idea for Uber.
Then why didn't you fucking do it,
Dick?
That's
what I think.
Joe.
Better words have never been spoken.
Jerry,
you're a bad motherfucker.
Thank you,
sir.
Pleasure meeting you.
So glad you did this.
Thank you.
Good night everybody.
We'll be back tomorrow.
Episode nine slash 11 with fucking Alex
Jones.
That's right.
You heard it.
And Eddie Bravo.
Holla.